did you celebrate halloween in the uk no
no right which is why it was like so
alien to me when uh secretary and stuff
like that yeah well we were like that we
there are some people who celebrate
halloween in the uk but it's certainly
not as massive as it is in america
because like i remember when i started
taking sydney and uh she was like asking
me oh what are we doing for halloween
what are we doing for halloween and i
was like i don't know i've never
celebrated halloween before there's a
horror movie i like watching horror
movies like oh we're going
trick-or-treating we're dressing up i
was like
dressing up for halloween in the uk is
going to like primark and buying like
five white t-shirts cut chopping them up
and calling yourself like a zombie or a
ghost or something like that that's like
that game is weak
that's the extent of dressing up in
halloween you you if you didn't
if if you spent more than one day
prepping your costume you put in [ __ ]
effort yeah but in america like i like
some of these costumes blow like anime
cosplayers out the [ __ ] windows yeah
right like it's [ __ ] interesting to
me what what blows my mind more than the
costumes is how dedicated some americans
are to like decorating their house oh
people are in the uk sometimes with like
the lights and like everything and like
because hockey did it this year as well
she was like she spent like three days
around the house putting like little
pumpkin things around and like putting
up like a broom to look like it was part
of a wish i'm like this is going to be
gone in two days
like why why are you putting this
majesty i get we're having like a house
party but like jesus christ yeah i
thought the cosplay was more than she's
been playing [ __ ] spooky scary
skeletons on the tv for like three days
straight i'm like i'm about to lose my
goddamn mind
i don't need all of this like pumpkin
[ __ ] around the house did you celebrate
it in australia uh so it depends so some
families do but i feel that
like every now and then like i did
trick-or-treating once in australia when
i was a kid but it was i mean compared
to like america it was pretty pathetic
that's the one thing growing up as a kid
that i was like why can't i do this like
that's when i felt like we live in a
society again i'm bringing it back i
felt so i felt like i've been so
positive
it's a week old now
get over it i feel like we've been
robbed a little bit growing up because
i'm what every single year you know i
i've thrown the cartoon network i watch
ed and eddie they have a halloween
special i watch carriage i know it's
always halloween i watch simpsons
simpsons halloween halloween special
halloween special huh always
trick-or-treating always
trick-or-treating and i'm like i
remember asking my mom can we can we go
trick-or-treating she's like oh you can
try
but like no one's gonna give you
anything yeah exactly
no one's going to have anything i was
like oh so how are you going to get
around you're going to walk the houses
are kind of far away from each other you
know i'm like oh oh oh i would always
live in like a cul-de-sac or something
isn't that how it works
there's no cul-de-sacs in the uk so it's
dangerous it's cul-de-sacs like little
arrows
and like like big
uh big um residential areas
kind of like
yeah in in brighton you we had
trick-or-treaters i remember when
trick-or-treating you did yeah yeah yeah
i remember went trick-or-treating like
once or twice and kind of
i i've never been you never been never
been i don't know i i thought it was
always overrated which is why like as a
kid i'm just like i have to talk to
strangers i didn't i didn't even do it
to collect candy i just threw eggs at
people's houses
[Music]
[Laughter]
no joey's a mysterious kid
i didn't even like my friend my friend
who was older than me that was a real
broad moment right my friend
talking about trick or treating
i was just gonna rob him
he's like i just egged people
my friend my friend was older than me at
the time like two or three years older
than me was like dude we're not doing it
for the candy we're doing it to [ __ ]
wreak havoc in the neighborhood and he
just handed me like a packet of eggs and
i'm like what do you want me to do with
this and he's like throw them joey was
the throw them at the house i didn't
even i didn't even like try and get
candy so he's just admitting to
destroying public property
the statue of limitations just got his
past gone and can't be arrested for this
anymore he's free to talk about his
crime it was great like i guess though
like my friend didn't tell me about like
why we would throw the eggs it's like
because that was the whole that was the
whole trick part right so you'd go up to
a house there was no choice in this yeah
no trick or treating
this is like milgram's experiment in
action
my mate told me he told me you go up to
the house right you do the whole trick
or treat yeah yeah sometimes you know
they'd be nice enough to give you some
candy then you were like all right cool
let's go to the next house you didn't
get that if they didn't oh my [ __ ]
god there were some people still some
people
some people just did not like wouldn't
have it like at all like they were like
i don't want these [ __ ] kids coming
up to my door to teach him a lot asking
for candy right so some people were
really [ __ ] rude about it right like
they just opened the door the moment
they would see some kids dressing up
they just [ __ ] slam the door bro and
that was the time when the eggs came
loose
[Music]
so what you would do is you'd [ __ ]
you know if they [ __ ] really shut the
door on you you'd run back onto the
street and just chuck a couple of eggs
at the
how many eggs did you bring with you so
my friend had like like like three
dozens of eggs right so like it was
enough for like maybe like you know a
street or two but the problem right was
when my friend told me about this
revelation yeah uh he didn't tell me
when to throw the eggs exactly so
what i ended up doing was just i would
just stand in the middle of the street
and just fire exit every house i saw
without even going up to the door
i didn't have any candy with me i was
like oh sit i can throw these how old
are you
it's like maybe 12.
so i just like let loose about like a
dozen eggs before my friend was like
what are you doing
you have to like get you have to ask you
have to try for the candy
just [ __ ] drive by to drive by the
[ __ ] neighborhood did nobody come out
and like [ __ ] slap you i mean i'd
just run away before that happened bro
it's like like a monty python skill or
something you're like bro you want to go
trick or treating sure and you you're
like the one weird kid
your mom your mom asked you to go
trick-or-treating with the neighbor's
kid the neighbor's kid
yeah it's like
i got some eggs i think half of the
illusion that was so enticing about uh
watching it on tv about trick-or-treat
is that like american candy just looked
cool
yeah british candy and british sweets
just looked like boring really yeah well
that's why i never like enjoyed it
because it was just like well what what
am i getting just like the most basic
british sweet scenario we have some
awesome australia we have like a dairy
milk and then america would be like we
have the toxic apple bottom or something
whoa what's that that's awesome yeah but
then that but then you'd hear about the
elusive uh what is it the the
what's the [ __ ]
cone-shaped like corn flavored [ __ ]
things candy corns candy corns yeah
what's that what's that you've
definitely seen it because you see it in
cartoons all the time it's it's the one
candy that all the kids like ew candy
corn
it's like it's like a white and orange
cone-shaped thing and apparently it
tastes like garbage i've i've never
tried it americans can probably vouch
that
every american i've talked to about
candy corns i don't think i've met a
single person that said that they liked
it
i can't believe you just [ __ ] egged
your entire neighborhood joey i mean
there's a reason why the reason why i
only did it joe's a little rascal he did
it once joey's one trick or treating his
bro he sent them a message
he doesn't need to come back he made it
i don't need the [ __ ] candy i just
want to wreak havoc no because it's
people like you why my my sea during
during halloween when i was growing up
we went through like an egging epidemic
right like literally like we we like in
our local supermarkets and tesco's and
everything we literally had to stop
selling eggs during halloween right oh
yeah because so many [ __ ] kids would
start egging egging out
they did that in swansea
because it was from the university
students
you needed to like uh like during
halloween you need to buy id for like
three things cigarettes alcohol and eggs
hide your eggs
you're like
you didn't even like tp a house jerry
that's that's the like that's like the
oh with the toilet rolls that seems like
the more annoying ass one yeah i i saw
people
on my street doing that no but i was
like you guys do the teepee i'll cover
it with eggs
i'll make the toilet paper extra sneaky
it's like a taran feather yeah put the
put the put the sticky substance on then
put something to apply it yeah oh my god
just like we're just revealing that
joey's like a domestic terrorist right
now what is going on here no man joey's
the hardest apparently little ones i
only did
i was
decades long case can be put to rest